das ist ein tiefschlag für die nasa der
staates teil eines glückte doch das ziel
wird wohl verfehlt technische probleme
verhindern es dass die internationale
raumstation iss erreicht werden kann
was bedeuten diese probleme des
saarländers für die zukunft der nasa
raumfahrzeug zum science-fiction-epos
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's
ich will kommen ja das ist ein
tiefschlag bei diesem ersten härtetest
waren allerdings keine menschen an bord
des bulligen raumschiffe starliner nur
eine puppe namens rosi ein test damit
bestens ausgestattet mit zahlreichen
sensoren so sollen die wichtigsten daten
während des starts und beim eintritt in
die schwerelosigkeit in der crew kapsel
gesammelt werden aber die wird es jetzt
nicht zur iss schaffen und auch nicht
werden es schaffen weihnachtsplätzchen
und geschenke für die iss-besatzung
langfristig gesehen soll der lufthansa
riese boeing mit den starliner auch
menschen transportieren amerikanische
astronauten und astronautinnen sollen im
auftrag der nasa zur internationalen
raumstation iss gebracht werden der plan
sah vor dass die einzelnen stufen der
rakete abgesprengt werden und sich die
kapsel auf den direkten weg 2 ss macht
am samstag um 14 uhr 27 unserer zeit
sollte sie dort andocken 400 kilometer
über der erdoberfläche eine woche sollte
die kapsel dort oben bleiben um dann
nach weihnachten auf die erde
zurückzukehren und zwar am 28
dezember 2009 10 landen sollte sie
mitten in der wüste von new mexico neun
monate nach ihrem us unternehmen spacex
hätte beugen damit als zweites privates
unternehmen eine raumfähre zur iss
geschickt und der staat selbst heute am
freitag den 20 zwölfter vom
weltraumbahnhof cape canaveral im us
bundesstaat florida verlief tatsächlich
reibungslos er war mit spannung erwartet
worden
denn er war in der vergangenheit
mehrfach verschoben worden
die atlas 5 der united launch alliance
von lockheed martin und wohin beute
pünktlich um 12 23 mitteleuropäischer
zeit ab und 15 minuten nach dem start
wurde die raumkapsel abgedockt doch nah
danach gab es wohl ein problem
am nachmittag hatte nasa chef jim
brittens teil dazu bei twitter
geschrieben
starliner in stable orbit rappen working
with jools cst 100 starliner sei jetzt
also in einem stabilen orbit allerdings
sei die raumkapsel nicht auf dem weg zur
iss sondern wird diese wohl verfehlen
der grund eine triebwerks zündung war
ausgeblieben die die raumfähre auf den
richtigen weg bringen sollte das team
puls wir jetzt welche test ziele
erreicht werden können können bevor das
raumschiff wieder sicher in mexiko lande
so heißt es auf der nasa webseite wenig
später dann ein weiteres update von nasa
chef jim bodenstein bei twitter hier ist
die rede von einer anomalie bei der
mission labs time das raumschiff kamen
so offensichtlich mit den zeiten
durcheinander und mehr treibstoff als
geplant wurde verbraucht zu wenig
treibstoff war also übrig um dies zu
erreichen so das zitat von daewoo mit
der iss verhindert wurde möglicherweise
wird der starliner jetzt schon in 48
stunden in der wüste von new mexico
nannten das ganze projekt gehört mit zum
sogenannten commercial crew programm der
nasa bei der private unternehmen
astronautinnen astronauten in den
erdorbit bringen sollen sowohl spacex
als auch boeing waren schon 2014 damit
beauftragt worden
raumschiffe für diesen zweck zu
entwickeln eigentlich sei der
ursprüngliche plan vor dass raumschiffe
bereits 2017 menschen zur iss bringen
sollten
doch der plan verzögerte sich da die
sicherheit der besatzung nicht
gewährleistet werden konnte doch die
nasa hat großes interesse daran
denn seitdem ändere ihre space shuttles
ist sie auf russland und deren sojus
raumschiffe angewiesen um zur iss zu
gelangen auch für deutschland ist das
projekt entscheidend dazu einen
mitarbeiter der europäischen
weltraumorganisation esa die idee
schmidt in einem interview mit der bild
für uns ist das sehr wichtig weil unsere
nächsten esa astronauten entweder auf
dem boeing starliner oder dem space
extraction fliegen werden
auch der deutsche astronaut matthias
maurer wird eine von diesen beiden
raketen nehmen nach plänen der nasa und
der esa soll auf die russische
sojus-rakete dann nur noch im notfall
zurückgegriffen werden doch mitte april
hatte es auch beim test des staates
abbruch systems der sp6 kapsel dragon
erhebliche probleme gegeben die dragon
kapsel war explodiert werden darüber
berichtet auch
diese raumfähre soll astronauten und
astronauten schon bald im auftrag der
nasa zur iss befördern doch die
sicherheitsbedenken sind weiterhin groß
und ein termin für bemannte flüge steht
weiterhin aus das raumschiff von spacex
allerdings hat bereits im märz 2009 10
einen ersten unbemannten testlauf zur
iss erfolgreich absolviert auch hier mit
dabei war ein dummy benannt nach der
hauptfigur der alien -filme ripley doch
was bedeuten die probleme des stars
jetzt für die zukunft wird es einen
weiteren test flugzeugs es geben
vielleicht sogar mit einer besatzung an
bord das alles wird sich erst in den
nächsten tagen klären wenn die genauen
ursachen des problems feststehen
abzuwarten bleibt ja auch erst einmal ob
die landung überhaupt gelingt sicher ist
jetzt jedenfalls das commercial crew
programm der nasa gerät weiter hinter
dem zeitplan
im moment steht in den sternen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes wann wieder
eine bemannte kapsel vom amerikanischen
boden in den weltraum fliegen wird space
ex raumfähre explodiert anklicken
anschauen und wenn es noch nicht getan
habt krieg substanzen fiction abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran